Speaker 1: Let's go. Oh, I don't know.
Let's go to our friend Eduardo from Brazil.
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
Speaker 1: Hey. How are you?
Speaker 2: I'm good. How are you doing?
Mazel tov on Argentina, by the way.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Very, very exciting.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Very exciting. So I have
one question for you. Sure. We're about to go to
transfer power here in Brazil to the president
on the first. Yes. To Lula and something that's
always been bothering me like a. Before, you know,
the sort of denying of election results has always
been kind of a third world country kind of fair,
you know, and and then Trump kind of pulled out
into his playbook for it were the big lie and
everything. So I guess my question to you is that
Trump kind of legitimized that for like developed
like like for like first world countries. Or is
it just becoming kind of this or Boris what? He
just kind of like creating their own playbook
according to, you know, sort of what usually
happened in sort of under developed countries?
Speaker 1: No, I think Trump absolutely
legitimized questioning the election results.
Whereas you're right. I mean, you know, just to
say that it was the sort of bailiwick of third
world countries, maybe it's sort of like more
accurate to say or maybe more precise that
questioning election results really just makes
your country look bad more than anything else. But
Trump figured out a way to do it where at least
among his followers, because he kind of couched it
as well. It was Democrats running elections, and
when it was Republicans running elections, it was
the Democrats doing the voter fraud and or it was
Democratic judges. But when it was Trump appointed
judges, then it was like the county commissioner.
You know what? It was just like a special pleading
no matter what. He figured out a way to do it
where his followers can say with a straight face,
We believe it was rigged without realizing what
that would suggest about the United States.
And I do think that it's being copied in other
countries, as you're pointed out, pointing out.
Speaker 2: Yeah. It's it's kind of concerning
because, you know, the fact that it's I mean, I
hate to say it, but it's kind of successful in
some way, shape or form. Yeah. By you seem like
a lot of people, you know, due to the cult of
personality or at least the man can do no wrong.
So if he says something, it's gospel, you know.
Speaker 1: Now, in Brazil, ah, the Bolsonaro
supporter saying it was stolen from him,
he really won.
Speaker 2:
Well, technically, he conceded, but his followers
haven't. Like I mean, I. I've been in Brazil for
about two weeks now. Yeah. And, you know, it
it's there's a very sort of uneasy feeling for
January 1st because there are still picket
lines. They still come out, you know, with
with the shirt. It's it's almost confusing because
every time you see, like a car with the Brazilian
flags sticking out you that automatically goes
that that's a likable scenario follower. Yeah,
but it's confusing with the World Cup because you
don't know if it's a World Cup kind of like flag.
But as Brazil left the World Cup. Yeah. So the
the there is a little feeling of unease here,
see, seeing what happens because a lot of people
haven't accepted it, even though he has conceded.
Speaker 1: Understand. Understand. Yeah. I mean,
listen, I, I don't know about in other countries,
but I think in the US Republicans saying if
they lost that it was rigged is going to be
with us for at least another election cycle.
Speaker 2: No, it's the new normal, which is
is worrisome for me because it's it's become
kind of part of the playbook. And, you know,
I just wanted to run it by it because it's
like the the legitimization of of, you know,
denying an election result and unfortunately
kind of fairly successfully done by Trump
is is scary because it's just kind of
like again crosses that Rubicon that
I don't think it will be hard to come back from.
Speaker 1: It's extremely scary. You're absolutely
right. Eduardo. Thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David. Take care.
Speaker 1: All right. There
goes Eduardo from Brazil.